everybody welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're gonna
pick up right where we left off last
week in the last stream and we're
getting free code camp to run locally so
when I say free code camp I mean the
lessons the curriculum on freak ok org
so if you didn't see the last dream
here's a quick recap of what we're
trying to do we want to make we want to
add some react native lessons so when
Faraday has created a react native
curriculum and we want to get that
running in the browser so react native
does not run in the browser you know
just as is but we can use react native
web to make it run in the browser so
step one is getting it getting the
curriculum to run locally which we
started last time so we'll finish that
up this time hopefully and we'll get
that running so I forgot to get my music
on
I usually stream with music in the
background because alright can y'all
hear me everything cut out for a second
I don't know what happened I think I'm
back alright I was weird there's
something with my internet I don't know
all right
but anyway I like to play music in the
background and then that way I speak a
little bit louder otherwise I tend to be
kind of a low a little kind of speaker
so I want to make sure y'all can hear me
ok so I'm gonna get some music playing
in the background alright I have a lot
of stuff in the chat right now so I'm
going to check on the chat and about 25
minutes or so
and then oh yeah there's a lot of stuff
so I'm just gonna say hey to everybody
and then I'm gonna check on the chat
about 25 minutes and I also want to let
everybody know that I probably won't be
streaming next week so probably won't
have another stream until the week after
so I'm gonna be in Chicago at the end of
the week for the react loop conference
so anybody in Chicago let me know I have
a very limited time in Chicago I'll be
there Thursday and then just in the
morning on Friday and then I'm gonna fly
back so if I know anybody in Chicago and
you want to hang out let me know quickly
and then maybe we can hang out on
Thursday and then after that I'm going
to come back on Friday afternoon and
then drive to the beach with my family
so I'll be going all week with them
and I'm not gonna try to stream from the
beach okay all right so let's see it's
been a week since we worked on this I
need to get up-to-date on this all right
so the last thing that we were working
on was trying to get [ __ ] to run
locally and that was our that was kind
of our challenge right also you know let
me get a Pomodoro clock running trying
to see where the best place to run this
is thought I had one up already but I
guess not
Pomodoro clock is just gonna be like a
25 minute timer
all right so this is our package.json so
if you these are the telling the
commands that we have were working with
right now see each so we're gonna want
to see the challenges but first we
actually need to I believe what we need
to do is get this running so let's check
out or I mean let me pull over a window
here browser window I thought I had one
going but from the last time I didn't
close anything from the last time but
you know how it is when you have too
many windows open it's easy you just
open a new one then then to find the one
you have open all right so we're gonna
go to github free code camp
and let's check out the contributing
guide if you're gonna do an open source
project sometimes you'll find there's a
contributing MD and always make sure you
read that you have a much better chance
of getting your pull request actually
merged if you follow the instructions
there we go
all right so we've done a lot of this
stuff yes we've done this
no interesting okay so they recommend
using docker I do not remember seeing
that last time so they I don't think I
have docker installed on this machine so
docker is like a container system
since we already started with the local
build stuff I think we'll just go on
with that maybe if I have time I'll
check out the docker thing and maybe
we'll switch to that but for now I think
this is probably probably the best way
to go
okay so we've done this environment
variable thing let's see we're not on
the docker boat okay so that's the
docker
we don't want that local boat okay
I'll leave over needs to be around only
the first time he said up the local
Devon
when this NPM CI is with some I do not
believe we ran a CI on NPM so let's do
that
also I believe we found that there was
kind of a different structure here so
there's learned I was being used so we
might and this is basically on the main
branch there's a different structure to
the project then on this branch the
react native challenges branch so we're
gonna have to maybe do it a little bit
differently so we'll we'll see if we
can't get this work and we'll see lerna
basically lets you have kind of a
structure where you you have like your
main project in a package.json at the
main level and then you have folders
within that that also have their own
package.json and it ties them all
together what if I can see an example
okay so like this is our main
package.json right and let's see if we
have another one here
yes sir then we have this this sub
package here with its own set of stuff
right so that's that's a le RNAs learner
so you could check it out if you want I
haven't used it for a project but I was
considering it for a project that I'm
working on so hopefully I know enough
about it that we can get through this
otherwise what to do a little more
research
alright let's go back to our Doc's are
contributing documentation hey and I
think I found the when I was originally
looking at okay on Windows let's see we
need to start MongoDB in a separate
terminal
okay so let's try to run this I don't
remember which one we installed
all right let's let's check out our
program files [ __ ] DB server 3.6 let's
see which one we did all right it opened
on another window let me just check this
out
see Program Files [ __ ] DB server all
right we have four point oh okay so you
should be able to just copy this and
we'll run this and we'll just run this
on another little spot another terminal
here I believe that was the command let
me double check that the [ __ ] D that's
that's what I think we had some issues
with commands not working so we'll see
if this works
oops nope that's not that's not it
how did we get that work in the Sun
let's see in the comments it says you
can add that path to your environment
variables and just run it typing [ __ ] D
in the terminal oh okay all right that's
cool
that works ratted to your environment
variables Oh or I can see D into that
folder and just run it from there you
know what that's how we that's how we
got it last time Thank You Brandon so
Brandon's saying that's where it got
stuck last time but that's what I just
realized
awesome okay so let's let's get that
work and I'm just gonna CD out of here
there we go what was it server yeah no
and then it was been after that was that
it yeah been okay there we go now we can
run this whoops I just need to run it
alright I'm check I'm checking the hmmm
he says I think adding it to the
environment variables is a better choice
to avoid CD every time yeah I think
you're absolutely right
I'm just doing it this way so that we
can try to get it started quickly but
yeah you're right I think there's some
setup that that should happen there
georgette says it looks like a live
stream on how to debug yeah that's
pretty much what this ends up being most
of the time we actually get stuff done
too but especially when we're starting a
project they're doing something new it
does end up being a lot of debugging all
right so we need to run the [ __ ] de XE
so let's see ok hmmm he's giving me the
command here
so let's go
okay all right cool let's see what
happened to you
come on go starting
the localhost
all right cool so it looks like it works
how many were I to me you're on Windows
that's it
I know and I normally develop on a Mac
so about I stream from PC so it's when
it this is definitely some differences
that I need to get used to so I probably
only use a PC I don't know like 5% of
the time that I want to computer
probably less apologies for being a
little rusty to the PC okay so I think
we have this working and so let's see if
we can go on to the next step which is I
believe seeding the database yep so
we'll do NPM run seed
okay cool that that looks like it's
working so you can please
insert it 200 new articles awesome okay
very cool and you should be able to type
NPM run develop and I'm doing so I'm
hoping that this part is all the same on
this branch and we'll find out in a
second okay I'm just I'm I'm not used to
switching between windows on a PC on a
Mac like there's really cool shortcuts
to just flip around different like
desktops sorry I'm so slow
oh it's doing stuff
oh yeah we're using Gatsby I forgot for
good camp was built with Gatsby
so we're getting a bunch of messages but
nothing that's like oh here we go
graph QL error challenge okay so we did
actually get an error here
interesting alright let's go to our
package.json and see if something if
it's different alright
I believe the seed command is different
but I mean not the command just like the
script so the name of the script
it looks like develops the same
hmm
interesting let's try okay and the chat
looks like a few year telling me to do
alt tab to change the windows let's see
ok cool when it brings up on my windows
awesome it's bringing them up on another
screen but like oh that's really cool
ok alright let's see so we typed in I'm
going to try to force myself to use this
alt tab dang it I must not have done it
right alright I need to get the hang of
this ok so we ran npm run develop but
did we ever run
yeah we didn't run any type of basically
what I'm looking at of these commands
here like this this stuff which is the
learner stuff so I think that's what I
want to run is this so there's a free
bishop post install okay
all right I'm gonna run some of these
I'm not a hundred percent sure that
these are what I need to run but let's
see
I lost my terminals there we go
I'm gonna cancel wait is that how it
works you maybe
oh just to get out here there we go it
just took a while to kill them all it's
such a violent command right to kill the
processes you could just say like stop
them shut them down okay I got about
four minutes until I'm gonna go to the
chat and answer some questions so if
you're you've been waiting for me to
read your comment just hang in there
almost all right so what I want to try
to run is this pre bootstrap bootstrap
and then I guess I can do pre bootstrap
and post install although it seems like
seems like this probably should have run
already after we did an NPM install but
I want to make sure that it actually ran
okay thank you for the shortcut for the
terminal who did that so so rub sorry if
I'm mispronouncing your name but thank
you for the command there okay alright
so let's try gonna do and this is gonna
do the inshore environment okay when he
said this stuff may have run already and
I just didn't catch it
alright now from what I know about
learner sees in my game they're shipped
in packages I think that this stuff
right already and
now let's try develop
all right so I'm kind of expecting we're
gonna get the same thing the same air as
we did before but I just wanted to try
it out just a few just in case up now
we're getting the same thing this
Braccio air unknown field challenge node
on type query on the news article node
all right so we're still having this
graph QL issues we did the seed right
we ran the seed command
what is this start develop should
develop okay so the develop command does
run start develop okay and it looks like
a sure environment okay so this already
runs
and we ran seed
okay I wanna see what we ran okay so he
did do seed so that should have seeded
challenges and news so that we do so
this command here that this seed and
then the little asterisk up here that
means it'll run all the commands that
have you know seed : so sure to see it
both
okay I think my timer yep my timer is up
I didn't get a notification so unless I
just missed it but anyway let's let's go
to the questions and then hopefully one
of us has some idea where to go next
because we keep hitting this graph QL
error all right I'm gonna scroll up to
the top try to get through as many
questions as I can
it's I have a few people asking me what
this is about
I explained it at the beginning and then
on the last stream that I did I also
explained a lot more so I'm gonna just
say like refer back to the beginning
Gabriel says what is what is the code
camp all about free code camp is a
nonprofit organization that helps people
learn how to code for free it has a lot
of things so it has the the lessons on
free code camp org that are like to talk
coding tutorials it has a bunch of blog
posts a YouTube channel a podcast a
whole like wiki site a forum so I'm not
probably missing out on stuff but
there's just a ton of resources for
people to learn how to code all of it is
completely free okay there's a ton of
stuff in the chat so I'm trying to
scroll through quickly apologies if I
miss your question rusty ass what
language is it we're gonna be using
javascript
Georgette's says hey Jessie do you think
you can create a series in which you
create an app with react native so
actually the the last project that we
worked on that we're not finished yet is
a react native app so we're gonna go
back to that once we get done with this
so that'll be project seven so you can
go back and look at all the project
seven videos on free code camp just just
my videos the live coding with Jessie
stuff to get an idea of how you would do
a react native that prints the boss says
do you use Pomodoro to get yourself into
the flow State when you start yes I do
try to use Pomodoro when I can at my my
normal job so I'm a software engineer at
Dick's Sporting Goods we do a lot of
pair programming it's kind of harder to
get in the flow State when you pair a
program but when I can I do try to get
in that flow State and I do use Pomodoro
Technique but it's not always possible
when your pair programming meltdown is
asking for a shout out hey meltdown
Gregory says wondering is there any free
code campers in Georgia
hey any free code campers in Georgia
give a shout in the chat or in the
comments
let's see ready answers can I afford
yeah yeah for sure you can fork this
repo anybody can contribute to the free
code camp repo it's not like there's no
prerequisites or anything well I guess
you have to be smart enough to get it
running which evidently I'm not there
yet but I'm gonna get there and memy
says hello Jesse how are you doing
hey I'm get someone all right pretty
busy this week getting ready for the
conference and for vacation and
everything but other than that I'm doing
all right thanks for asking
Gulin says do you have save recordings
of your teaching JavaScript and HTML
yeah so all my live streams are recorded
and they're saved on here on the free
code camp channel just search for live
coding with Jesse or check out the mmm
sorry check out the live coding with
Jesse playlists you can also check out
my youtube channel the links in the
description I have some tutorial videos
there and also some live streams there
and I'm gonna try to put out a video
before I go on go to my conference or
before I go to vacation on vacation this
next week so I haven't decided exactly
what the topic will be but I'd like to
do another kind of short tutorial video
since I haven't done one for a while
okay
I didn't get through everything so I'm
gonna mark down the time stamp where I
left off so I can go right back to it
mmm he says I think if you empty your
cache and try again the arrow will go
okay let's see all right that's where
the shot empty how much was the empty my
cash mmm is a silly question but let me
know I'm not sure who's who's I've says
looks like you're really tired I'm tired
it's it's a it's not that early here
it's 742 a.m. so it's not super early
but I'm a little tired
okay somebody asked me how many people
are watching right now that's a good
question I didn't really check 123
people right now so that's kind of cool
that's that's a decent amount of people
all right but let us just do a clean
build all right let's get this out of
here
I'm gonna hide this on the side just for
a second here because we don't really
need it also going to give us some more
space here okay
nobody keep any comments about why is it
so dark down here
it's dark right now because well number
one it's it's dark outside because it's
raining
yes it's very cloudy I'm also in a
basement so it's pretty it's pretty dark
and I just left the lights off because
there's less glare on the screen it's
the it's okay alright I guess we could
try oh I know what I wanted to do so we
are running on a on a fork on a
different branch so it may be that there
are different instructions so let's go
[Music]
here we go we're gonna go to Gwen
Faraday's repo and there we go we're
gonna go to her branch and see if no I
don't think so I was hoping that there
are updates to the contributing file but
I think there is
actually we would want this file right
setup free code camp locally
you're just trying to see if there's a
difference here or I don't think there
is no definitely not okay
the price you just opened the locals
just yeah just to verify that it's not
gonna run
okay so we got some more so her mommy
says that's what I found on github
Gatsby page the error was found before
you can search for the error message on
Google and you'll find the steps okay
cool thanks Mme so let's just Google
that error I'm not sure which which
error
I don't feel
let's just grab this one all right well
maybe say we get you a NPM cache clean
whoa
so fuel subscription she's interesting
I
I can force this command if I want to
just do that I love it you're using
force I sure hope you know what you're
doing all right cool
and I believe the command that they said
was
let's try that also let's look up I want
to go back to the free code campaigning
and I want to try to look this error
yeah I didn't think that this air would
come up specifically yes the issues
yeah this was like same error
yeah I don't think that's it all right
cool so let's try this develop that's it
oops you seasoned yarn and you don't
have the type run with that
okay the same thing
I'm checking the chat here to see what
advice everybody has
it looks like
it looks like we're still going with you
need to look up the air
my first builds okay it's just so after
a second run
the mummy said MPM cache clear works for
me works for no error from me okay
I was interesting want to run this again
that the other person there that had
that error
there we go said when they ran it a
second time it worked now we already
tried twice in a row so I'm not really
hopeful that this will work but good
shot I mean that's an easy fix if it
works you have to wear
doesn't look like we're not alone in
this
it also means a lot of stuff we need to
go through the update schema step should
be processed without errors all right
that that looks very close to what we
have in terms of what the air is reduce
this and getting it on the first run
regardless cache cleared
it's not really giving a solution
alright let's go back to the chat see
what y'all have to think or would you
off to say think Vera says what repo are
you using for the fort good question
I'm using so as well so this one so Gwen
Faraday's Fork of free cut camp so it's
not directly from free code camp it's
it's off of her for the reason I'm using
her Fork is because she has react native
lessons on there so that's what we need
to work with
okay Fernando says are you missing a
module I'm not sure because I see
successful a second run after clearing
the cache all right mommy says
successful after second when after
clearing the cache see that's not Mme
I'm so glad you got a success but I'm
not getting a success here so we did
clear the cache but we're not getting or
not getting any success here
now it is it's possible that there's
some difference because of this
particular branch on this Fork and maybe
I just need to talk to Glenn and see
after second second time after clean cut
I mean I guess we can try to clear try
to do it clear again
okay so this is just the same one who's
who's IVA
keeps saying that they saw ghosts behind
me
as long as the ghost helps me debug this
I'm okay with that
yeah this is the one we just started
every time the characters clear
all right let's clear
let's clear this and how many are you
using the same fork and branch that I am
okay I'm at me saying the cause of the
air is Gatsby in not graph QL that's
what I understood don't know all right
let's see you know what let's run I
actually think all that runs so there's
definitely a difference so I believe all
this stuff with Lara is not present in
the main free code camp branch and the
documentation we're running off of is
based off of that maybe that's where the
difference is coming in
okay
the only other thing I can think of is
clearing the cache and completely
removing all the note files but it looks
like it's remove existing node modules
before install so it says it's doing
that let's try this out now
I cannot read properly minimum level
undefined I'm gonna take a look at what
we're getting here a little bit more
closely
i Mme says you can try
can you try using a newer version of
gasping graph QL John Hanson says I
recently had a similar issue turned out
to be Windows 10 path issue I cleaned
that path variables and ran another pair
of fix it for me oh okay
John could you walk me through that Ben
so this is interesting so like I
mentioned before I don't normally
develop on Windows so maybe this is some
sort of Windows thing how many are you
on a PC to
I'm also gonna run this just one more
time since this would be the second time
after clearing the cache again which
worked before for for Mme
and I got about three minutes before the
next timer goes off and then I'm gonna
go back and answer some more questions
I'd love to get something running so so
far we got [ __ ] running which we didn't
get running last time I don't think so
we had one small win
all right so that did not work all right
so John saying NPM config path prefix
should show the path
then Nanoha
Kela says guess be clean John says open
environment variables in Windows
we're gonna open environment variables
we're going to find this
you need like is there a search on
Windows or can I search for stuff on
Windows there we go type here to search
[Music]
I'd opened on another screen let me move
this over
all right environment they're clearing
the castles ok how many was on Ubuntu ok
ok make sure you pass this the variable
inclusion ojs pass environment variables
okay
okay
and could you know jazz path
I'm guessing is that would that be the
right path I'm showing users Jessie app
data roaming NPM
in the paths on the system variables oh
sorry sorry
okay let's see what we got here okay
all right yeah Program Files nodejs
is here
should I have something separate for NPM
alright John says the path looks fine
for node yes so I guess it's not a path
thing
okay
I've seen wonderful now good add or
remove programs
I know this is some some legit debugging
here debugging windows so we found out
and we're gonna run run repair
or modify and repair repair we're gonna
repair now I hope this works and it's
helpful for somebody out there
all right well this is happening I'm
gonna read some questions and stuff oh
it finished already huh I guess I'm not
gonna read questions well it's John
Ensign says you may want to reboot the
system all right well I'm not gonna
reboot in the middle of a stream so that
might have to wait until the next stream
the only other thing I thought of doing
was so I could do yarn develop and see
if it does anything different and I know
it seems weird but like I have had it
happen before that a command will work
with yarn but not with NPM so it's worth
it
worth a try it looks like nope same
thing same air
I'm gonna do that and I'm also gonna do
to clean out the node module I'm taking
out node modules and the package lock
JSON doing like the legit destroy
everything
whoa let's try this
all right so that'll take a little bit
and I can go back to the questions now
all right so I'm scrolling all the way
up to where I left off hopefully I don't
miss anything
Georgette's says why didn't you continue
your last episode react native on
browser actually this is a continuation
in the last episode this is kind of the
first step in that
alright cool that took less time than I
thought it would
and
so the necks
nope same there
may as well run it twice since since the
people on on github had success trying
to run it twice not really that hopeful
at this point though I don't think we're
gonna get this to work doing today's
stream which is alright it may just be
that since we did the repair I just need
to restart my computer I'm not gonna do
that obviously because if I do that it's
gonna cut the stream off so I'll have to
do that after the stream and then
hopefully it'll work for the next stream
also I'll probably reach out to Glen and
ask if there's anything special I need
to do since her project is set up
differently so let me I want to show you
just so that maybe it's a little bit
more clear like how this what I mean by
set up differently all right so if we
look at like the package.json for this
and then we go to the normal free code
camp master branch and look at the
package.json see if it's it looks like
there's learn in here now maybe I had an
older version
see there's a lot more going on here now
I wonder
the last time
all right so the last commit to this was
on February 10th about this one January
6 it's possible
and alas commit on this was three days
ago it's entirely possible that there
have been some breaking changes and
that's why we can't get it working
so I wonder
I wonder if it would be a better idea
and I don't have time to do it today but
it would be a better idea to try to get
free code camp running from like its its
latest updates from the main repo just
to get it running and then we can pull
over like let's say one of the
challenges that when did as a test to
try to get that running because as long
as we get it running
then one could incorporate that into
what she's doing and then eventually
hopefully that can get put into the free
code camp curriculum so everybody can
learn some basics of react native I am
gonna try to do a restart on my machine
just to see if I get it working if that
doesn't work then I think we're gonna go
with that plan let me know what you all
think about that plan so the the back-up
plan here is clone so fork and clone the
main free code camp repo with the latest
changes and try to get it running based
on that cuz that's we're using
documentation from the latest repo but
we're trying to get something to run
that hasn't been updated since February
10th so it's entirely possible that
that's part of our issue so the plan is
use the main repo next time if we can't
get this one to work let me know what
you think of that plan if you have a
better plan if there's something I'm
missing here that's like obviously a bad
idea
let me ask what exactly is Gatsby Gatsby
is just uh I don't know we were to say
like a tool or something like to build
sites with with react I guess I don't
know how to explain it more than than
that from what I understand and I
haven't read up on Gatsby I tried to use
it in a long time but you can use
markdown and then that gets changed into
like actual like web pages so I think a
lot of people use Gatsby for for blogs
and they can write their stuff in
markdown
all right and I'm not gonna read all the
comments out I'm just kind of going for
the questions now cuz I'm running out of
time here so apologies if I'm not
reading out your comment I am looking at
them I'm just not reading them out loud
georgette says what is fourth mean so
Fork is if you go on github to a repo
you can fork the repo and that means
that it just takes everything in this
repository and it copies it on to your
github account so that you can then work
on that code without affecting the main
repository so usually if you're going to
contribute to a repository of the
processes forked it first then clone
your fork so that you can run it locally
and make changes and then if you change
your fork you'll have the option of then
submitting a pull request to the main
repository and whoever controls that
repository can decide whether or not
they want to merge that pull request
which means your code will then become
part of their code part of the main
repository I did check out my youtube
channel
I believe I did some git and github
videos that explain this in more depth
so I guess check that out if you need if
you want more info about that I think
that I did do I have done some live
streams where I've done that whole
process before I don't remember what the
exactly what the titles of those streams
are though I see says I want to learn
programming from you can you please send
me your direct contact number of future
correspondents I have some links to my
social media stuff in the description if
you want to send me a DM or something
that's cool I'll try to help you out
Yosi says where am i from I'm from the
United States specifically I was born
and raised in West Virginia which is a
part of the United States and right now
I live in Ohio and I work in Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania and in the United States I
I see a couple questions about like what
am i coding what it's going to be if you
go back and watch the last stream the
last video to the project eight day one
I go through all of that of like what
I'm building and what we hope to
accomplish
yeah mate memo says basement sleep last
dark theme dark room good probability of
having no girlfriend or whatsoever this
guy is epic
hashtag real-life programmer well I'm
sorry to disappoint you but I am married
and I have four kids so I don't fit all
of that but I am in a basement
I do have dark theme everything and I'm
in a dark room the sleep sometimes I
can't sleep sometimes I don't but it's
not really about programming it's more
about like which kids wake up
whose his office says are you a gamer by
the way at a former gamer I don't have a
lot of time for games right now I do
like them I just I don't have a lot of
time to play
love you video right right hound says
love your videos please make a basic
tutorial of complete react Jess how to
use templates yeah maybe I'll do some
basic react.js stuff at some point
usually I put the tutorials on my
youtube channel links in the description
to that except an updated that channel
in a little while but I'd like to do
another video sometime this week for
that channel
nimma says what's a good way to learn a
low-level language I don't really know a
good way like for me a good way for me
to learn anything is I try to find free
resources online do the tutorials watch
the videos read the documentation and
then if I really want to learn something
actually building a project with it is a
great way to learn
[Music]
Randy Keller says what kind of fancy
typewriter is that very fancy typewriter
I lost my place I don't know why I'd it
just get down
it moved my scroll all the way down to
the end of the chanson oh I lost my
place let me see if I can find it again
all right I did
georgette there was a question but I
think it was directed at somebody else
and not at me
do you prefer Python or JavaScript
I'd prefer JavaScript because I'm better
with it
I don't have anything against Python
I've used it before and I kind of like
it but I'm definitely better with
JavaScript now George head says you
should rename the live stream as a
series of debugging yeah honestly that's
all it's been so far we're gonna
actually do something at some point but
I've got to get the setup down first
I've always one of these dreams to be
like a realistic look at what it's like
to be a developer or software engineer
and realistically a lot of time is spent
debugging like things like this happen
so that's why I leave stuff in here I
don't edit the stream so I don't delete
streams like because as as weird as it
is to have a live stream like this and
not actually get very much done like
sometimes that's the way it is when you
actually you know working at a company
okay so I had mentioned my so so I
noticed somebody put in a derogatory
remark I'm assuming it was meant to be
derogatory I don't know but I just
deleted it so just as a reminder
everybody we try to stay positive here
so and georgette thank you for putting
that message in about no negativity here
so we stay positive if I see anything in
the chat like I'm just gonna delete it
I'm not gonna argue with anybody like so
just you know if that's your thing
this really maybe isn't you're not gonna
have a good time in here if you want to
be negative there's enough negativity
elsewhere in the world and online so but
here we try to stay positive so just a
reminder to everybody you know keep it
keep it positive I mentioned the idea of
let's just try to go with the Maine free
code camp branch next time John I
believe in response to that says that
sounds like a good idea I got some
thumbs up for that so I think that's
probably what we'll wind up doing
i editi SS what are skills required for
a president web developer I mean the the
skills that you need to be able to like
learn fast on your own because
everything changes so quickly so problem
solving skills as well now in terms of
like technical skills
I mean HTML CSS JavaScript for sure you
definitely need that for web development
anything else on top of that is really
gonna depend on what the particular
project is you know and what your client
or your company uses but if you know
HTML CSS and JavaScript you're gonna
have a good foundation to pick up
anything else
Dale asks if the stream just started or
it's ending its ending now but you can
always watch the recordings the
recording will be available
sweetie sweetie sweetie yes what are you
doing right now
right now I'm just answering questions
in the live chat did the body asks for
blockchain tutorials I did do some
blockchain live streams on my youtube
channel so the link to my channel is in
the description you can check that out
it was a while ago but I used solidity
to do some like aetherium apps so maybe
you know you can check that out I'm no
expert at it but if you want to kind of
see what it's like just you know check
it out
all right cool so I got through all
questions like I said I did read
everything I read all the comments so
there's a lot of a lot of people were
complimenting and I appreciate that
thank you so much I'm gonna wrap this up
now and like I said I probably won't
stream again and so maybe like July or
maybe the very end of June because I
have conferences and vacation coming up
but I'll be on social media so if you
want to talk to me there I'll definitely
be there I'm on Twitter and Instagram a
lot and I'm gonna try to put out a video
on my youtube channel this week as well
so if you if you want to talk to me go
ahead again I'm gonna be in Chicago at
the end of the week so if I know anybody
in Chicago reach out to me maybe we can
hang out get some coffee or something on
Thursday Thursday I'll probably the only
day I'll be able to hang out of this
week all right so thanks everybody it
was against you I had fun in this dream
it was good
I mean it's we found didn't really fix
what we were trying to fix but that's
the way it goes sometimes so we got a
good plan for next time I'm excited
about that I think we will get it to
work next time and yeah so until then
have a great next couple of weeks and
yeah thanks again for watching